It's Taipei's newest hotspot: a ninja-themed restaurant.
From the outside, you can't miss it:...
...orange-clad ninjas crawl up the side of the building,...
...but enter the dining room and you may have trouble locating the door,...
...it's hidden under a waterfall.
I think the idea is really cool, normal people wouldn't think about it.
The door we came through though, is really special.
You can only see the waterfall and you wonder what to do,...
...then you realize it's a door.
Once inside, customers can choose from a menu of Japanese cuisine...
...listed on paper scrolls.
Patrons are served by waitresses in ninja outfits...
...who wield swords and pens that look like throwing darts.
Some of the customers take the swords,...
...so we are going to write something on them,...
...for example, sea cucumber or maybe drinks,...
...and you will get what you see on the sword.
But if it says 200 in tips, then you have to tip us 200.
Big tips or not, Taiwan's Ninja Restaurant...
...is giving new meaning to eating on the edge.
Julie Noce, Reuters.